pour le groupe de l'Union centriste
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre mesdames monsieur les
rapporteurs chers collègues un premier
mot à nouveau pour saluer les
rapporteurs leur travail à la fois sur
le fond du texte mais aussi du point de
vue de l'analyse et puis sur la méthode
et saluer leur leur calme leur
modération c'est important le calmer la
modération on vient de le voir
alors capacité de d'écoute de dialogue
d'échanges et de pédagogie et même leur
sens de la formule ils viennent d'en
faire la démonstration votre travail
grandit notre institution le Sénat et
donc merci nous sommes rassemblés ce
matin pour discuter d'une motion
référendaire je veux tout de suite au
nom du groupe UC dire mais sans l'ombre
du hésitation que nous ne la voterons
pas pour des raisons
d'opportunités mais également pour des
raisons de fonds du point de vue de
l'opportunité nous sommes rassemblés
pour débattre de l'avenir de notre
système de retraite et pour nous il
serait tout à fait inopportun de refuser
ce débat exonérer du débat sur les
retraites ici et maintenant en
choisissant le référendum cela
reviendrait pour nous à refuser
l'obstacle et ça c'est pas une méthode
pour nous voilà pour l'opportunité sur
le fond notre groupe j'ajoute à partir à
une tradition politique qui pense que le
référendum doit être réservé à la
matière institutionnelle pour les
questions sociétales comme pour les
questions économiques et sociales nous
pensons que c'est le rôle du Parlement
de débattre et de voter j'ajoute que
cette motion référendaire la votée
reviendrait à créer un redoutable
précédent parce que ça nous interdirait
pour longtemps de débattre des retraites
ici au Parlement parce que pourquoi on
fera un référendum maintenant et par
ensuite sur des débats comme ça et
pourquoi sur des questions aussi
essentielles que des questions
sociétales économiques et sociales on
demanderait pas systématiquement à
référendum et donc un précédent comme
cela serait tout à fait irresponsable ce
serait d'ailleurs porté un bien mauvais
coup à la démocratie parlementaire donc
pour nous c'est clairement bon à cette
motion référendaire je veux à présent
profiter de temps qu'il me reste pour
discuter du texte sur les retraites mais
aussi du contexte de ce débat
vous l'avez compris hier au travers des
interventions de Hervé Marseille et de
Jean-Marie valrownberg notre groupe
c'est clairement positionné pour cette
réforme un oui mais alors quand on dit
oui mais quelquefois c'est un petit oui
un grand mais non là c'est une forme
d'équilibre et c'est un oui mais c'est
un oui bien sûr et un mai parce qu'il
faut améliorer ce texte ce sera
d'ailleurs dans une double volonté une
un certain équilibre bien sûr mais la
volonté d'enrichir ce texte notamment
sur les pour les femmes les familles les
carrières longues et l'emploi des
seniors nous saluons et approuvons
d'ailleurs les avancées de la Commission
en termes d'équité en termes de justice
mais nous proposerons aussi par
l'intermédiaire de quelques amendements
d'aller plus loin encore tout en
veillant à l'équilibre financier du
texte c'est fondamental cette question
de l'équilibre financier de cette
réforme parce qu'il faut qu'elle vaille
la peine sinon les Français ne
banqueraient pas de nous dire tout ça
pour ça et ils auraient raison un
système de retraite repose sur la
solidarité entre les voilà pourquoi je
ne comprends toujours pas la timidité du
gouvernement en matière de politique
familiale à l'aube de ce débat sur les
retraites le choix du gouvernement lors
du dernier PPL FSS il faut le rappeler
d'avoir privé la branche famille de 2
milliards d'euros m'apparaît encore plus
aujourd'hui totalement inapproprié c'est
pourquoi l'un de nous amendements phares
sera celui qui prévoit une mesure d'âge
ça va pas plaire sur certains bancs tout
simple la retraite à 60 ans pour les
familles de deux enfants et 64 ans pour
les familles de trois enfants et plus je
ne crains pas d'assure d'assumer on est
un certain nombre ici dans cette
hémicycle l'urgence d'une politique
familiale et nataliste au moment où la
France ne renouvelle plus les
générations avec un taux de natalité
inférieur à deux ça sonne comme une
évidence bien sûr vous l'avez compris
notre groupe est très attaché à notre
système de financement de retraite par
répartition c'est pourquoi nous voulons
aborder ce débat les yeux ouverts et en
toute lucidité se donner les moyens de
financer la retraite de plus de 20
millions de retraités et non seulement à
des films et une exigence morale qui
impose d'imposer d'anticiper les besoins
de financement croissants nous
partageons le principe que seul le
travail et je dirais même l'augmentation
de la quantité de travail produite pour
notre pays peut garantir le financement
de notre protection sociale et donc le
financement de la branche vieillesse et
des retraites mais au-delà de la
question du financement nous sommes
attachés à la valeur travail ce n'est
pas sur les bancs du groupe UC que se
fera entendre un éloge de la paresse
c'est pourquoi il nous semble
indispensable d'organiser dans les
meilleurs délais un début de base sur le
travail et la rémunération des salariés
j'ai la conviction que les partenaires
sociaux sont prêts à aborder cette
discussion en responsabilité un tel
débat sur le travail nous permettra
d'aborder dans la sérénité je le répète
cette question essentielle de l'emploi
du seniors un index le Seigneur est un
premier geste il est nécessaire mais
sera-t-il suffisant j'ai bien peur que
la réussite de cette réforme passe par
la possibilité de tous et tous de
s'épanouir dans son emploi jusqu'à 64
ans d'ailleurs pour nous le débat sur le
travail est indispensable pour preuve un
sondage publié hier démontre combien les
Françaises et les Français en viennent
parfois à douter de l'importance du
travail au lendemain de la crise covid
ainsi je ne me résous pas à lire que 58%
des Français contre 49 en 2019 voit le
travail comme une contrainte quand 42%
seulement il voit un moyen de se
réaliser ils étaient
51% en 2019 avoir un moyen de se
réaliser ce recul est alarmant pour
notre pays je refuse de compter parmi
les déclinistes mais reconnaissons que
ce changement profond s'il venait à
durer s'il est anthropologique est un
germe de déclin de notre pays ce débat
sur le travail dans la société poskovite
doit permettre d'approfondir de nombreux
sujets je comprends je pense au travail
de seigneur je le répète à une
augmentation des salaires à la veille du
retour de l'inflation conséquence peu
surprenantes du quoi qu'il en coûte et
de l'injection massive d'argent public
dans l'économie je pense à la pénibilité
des métiers je pense à la question des
métiers en tension je pense enfin à la
formation tout au long de la vie qui
doit donner à celle et à ceux qui en ont
la volonté de pouvoir changer une métier
le bien-être au travail l'épanouissement
au travail voilà le défi auquel nous
sommes collectivement confrontés même si
nous pensons qu'il faut aller plus loin
en termes d'équité de justice nous
faisons le pari qu'il y aura une réforme
des retraites mais au lendemain de
l'adoption de cette réforme il y aura
obligation de recoudre notre tissu
social et ce sera notre dernière
remarque au nom du groupe UC comme la
formule est hier notre Président nous
demandons l'organisation d'une
conférence sociale qui pourra avoir pour
objectif la refondation du paritarisme
pour recréer la confiance dans ce pays
qui est dégradé la rémunération des
salariés et puis la place du travail
dans nos vies mais chers collègues vous
l'avez compris notre groupe a envie de
débattre d'aller au bout de ce débat de
conclure ce débat c'est le rôle et la
mission et la responsabilité du Sénat et
donc pour toutes ces raisons que je
viens dénoncer notre groupe de votre APA
cette motion référendaire je vous
remercie merci
[Musique]
je vais donner la parole au président
Jean-Claude Roquier pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen